foreign
West Virginia is where we're going to go
now Luke is there Luke how can we help
hey how we doing guys we are having a
blast what's going on with you
oh I'm doing very well too I'm working
on um getting out of debt and basically
I was talking to my dad about that
during Christmas and my Dad tried to
tell me being debt free as a pipe dream
will never exist and I said oh why do
you say that he tried to convince me
that electric bills water bills utility
bills car insurance are debts and I
don't believe that to be true
wow man this guy needs a hug is your dad
doing okay
yeah he had a stroke a few years ago but
he's recovered well now on him and I you
know we spend a lot of time together
when I visit and we get along great but
for some reason his perception of money
is not great he lives with my
grandparents his parents and I just
bought my first house this last year so
maybe jealous I don't know well I think
truthfully there's something underneath
that where he's been hurt when it comes
to money and he feels like he's never
gonna get ahead and that's where that
attitude comes from I remember I did my
debt-free scream on the show and you
know we uploaded to YouTube and all the
comments were just like your dad's well
you're not really debt free you'll
always have bills to pay you'll never be
it's a pipe dream man and so I know that
feeling and I because it's been told to
me before and the truth is your utility
bills are not debt no it's it's you have
it's just an expense that's all right
it's a purchase I'm purchasing
electricity this moment I am purchasing
I'm purchasing water George this month I
mean you have to think they're not
borrowing money
you're simply purchasing those utilities
does that help you philosophically you
get that
yeah kind of like if I pay cash for a
car it's not dead I had to pay for it
but it's not a dead thing that's correct
that's correct when you go to the
restaurant you order a meal you didn't
borrow money you went ahead and ate it
then they brought you the bill
and that's how utilities work you had
light the entire month and now you have
to pay for it you don't have to live off
the grid to live a debt-free lifestyle
that doesn't mean you'll never have any
expenses again it means you'll never
have payments to make for borrowing
money with interest again which makes
your life better the whole goal is to
minimize expenses to create as much
margin as possible to create the life
that we want and you are doing that and
so say hey thanks Dad appreciate the the
kind word but uh yeah I'm gonna keep
living my life yeah change the
conversation